Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters.
This is just a little introduction to your protocol binder.
Your protocol binder will be sent to you.
It's actually a hard three-ring binder after we do your cheek swab testing.
So this is the data from your cheek swab testing.
So when we got your cheek swab back,
I personally do the testing on your cheek swab.
And this is where we come up with the data,
what we believe the major cause is.
Now we're doing the other testing as well to get down to specifics.
So that's why we look at genetics.
That's why we look at toxicity testing.
We want to get to specifics of cause.
But with the cheek swab test, we're coming up with the general cause,
what we believe the cause of this whole thing is happening.
That's what we want to get to.
Remember, stop treating the cancer.
We have to treat the cancer too, but you got to treat the cause.
So we're going to get to the cause and figure out what's going to help deal with that.
Pull that out, detoxify it, kill it, whatever it is.
And then we're also going to get to your protocol as far as specifics.
That has to do with diet and specific nutrition.
Remember, we don't want you to have 40 different supplements if we can help that.
We want you to have five, six, seven, eight things that are going to be specific to you.
And remember, those can change.
So we're going to recheck your cheek swab again in 60, 90 days, whatever I recommend with the testing.
We're going to recheck it because your your dietary feeders,
the fuel source to the cancer can change over time.
Let's say the fuel source of your cancer is meat.
Did I take you off of all meat?
So not real common, but let's say that's pretend that.
So we're taking you off of all meat, all pork, all fish, all poultry, everything.
Well, that can change.
It doesn't mean you're going to be on that diet for the rest of your life.
Personally, for me, when my cancer was really bad,
I had to go off of meat.
Meat was a driver for my cancer for a period of time.
Now I'm basically a carnivore, so I eat meat all the time.
So, but it was a period of time I was pretty much off of most meat for about six months.
And everybody's going to be on a low-carb diet all the time,
any all yourselves feed off of glucose.
So we have to keep our carbs, our sugars down,
because cancer is always going to feed off of that,
but cancer will find fuel sources.
So we need to tweak this and change this.
So remember, your binder is a living document.
It's going to be changed over time as you progress and start to get better
and things change, or you are doing well for a period of time,
and then all of a sudden it takes off.
Same thing with your specific supplement plan.
Don't think you're going to be on the supplements forever.
Typically, we recommend getting a 60-day supply.
You'll most likely almost always be on it for at least 60 days.
And then we may tweak it, but don't buy a six-month supply of stuff,
because you may not be on it,
probably won't be on those things for that long.
It can change, so just remember that.
Also, in your binder,
you're going to have some affirmations to start reading,
and start studying, and start putting it into your head,
that you believe that God has a purpose for you,
and you're here for a reason,
and even this disease has a purpose.
Let it drive you to a deeper relationship with Him.
Let it drive you to a deeper faith with Him.
And always, like I said, there's going to be updates.
We're always going to have updates to your binder and such too.
So all the basics of the three-reg binder
are going to be on the member's site as well.
So if you're a full comprehensive member,
you'll see updates coming out there,
and videos coming out there,
to make sure you're checking that as well.
But follow your binder as best you can.
If you have questions, make sure you contact us.
Well, you get your binder, and you have it.
You can read through it.
You're going to actually have full call with me,
and we're going to go through it together,
so there's no misunderstanding or confusion as well.
And we're always here for you.
And make sure if your comprehensive member
jump on the Zoom calls and ask questions on that too.
All right, God bless.
We'll see you soon.